our story doesn't begin in the lands
between
it begins in the cosmos far away with an
outer God called the greater will
there are a lot of outer Gods mentioned
in Elden ring you can think of these
kind of like the great ones of
bloodborne they're distant beings
they're all powerful and they're quite
unknowable by Design but many of these
outer Gods want to make their presence
felt in the world the greater will may
be most of all to this end it sent a
golden star hurtling towards the lands
between the olden Stars incantation
tells us that this golden star was
bearing a beast an Elden Beast the Elden
remembrance calls it a vassal beast of
the greater will if you didn't know a
vassal is someone who holds land on
behalf of their Overlord obviously this
is fitting in this case because the
Elden Beast occupied the lands between
on behalf of the greater will and was a
living incarnation of the concept of
order as such this Beast would later
become the Eldon ring the Elden ring
itself is made up of Runes of power some
great some small that together represent
a sort of logic for the world to follow
thus the Elden ring represents order the
true nature of this order is a subject
of constant debate and research
undergone by fundamentalists but two of
the key fundamentals are the laws of
causality and regression you can think
of the law of causality as cause and
effect where actions have consequences
and those consequences are new causes
that Branch out into Infinity these are
the relationships between things then
there's the law of regression that
states that all things eternally yearn
to converge and return to their Roots
fittingly then the Elden ring is housed
within the urge tree which Towers over
the lands between but it's very
important to stress that life in the
lands between did not begin with the
herd tree the Elden ring or or the
eldenbeast know the lands between were
occupied well before the greater will
came there were other beings here there
were other factions here there were
other gods here and there was even
another great tree here before the herd
tree
and this is where a huge twist regarding
the urge tree comes in so there are
incantations in the game called aspects
of The Crucible according to their
descriptions these are manifestations of
the erdtree's Primal vital energies and
I quote they are an aspect of the
primordial Crucible where all life was
once Blended together
but how could all life be Blended
together in the urge tree if the Earth
tree appeared after life existed well
there can only be one answer right that
the Earth tree is a parasite and it took
over a tree that existed here before
this ancient tree was called the Great
tree
so the great tree was almost certainly
the location of this primordial Crucible
and it must have been a very powerful
primordial Force for the greater will to
have commandeered it might even be the
reason the lands between is important to
the greater will in the first place it
also explains why spells and enemies
related to the great trees Crucible
would eventually be looked down upon for
example the not Talisman is fashioned
from a knotted Vestige of The Crucible
and it was considered a signifier of the
Divine in ancient times but is now
increasingly disdained as an impurity as
civilization has advanced enemies
related to The Crucible are the omen the
Miss begotten and The Crucible Knights
and all three of them would be shunned
enslaved or imprisoned those who speak
for the urge tree don't want you to know
its roots so to speak according to the
spell protection of the old tree in the
beginning everything was in opposition
to the Earth tree but through countless
victory is in war it became the
embodiment of order in America's own
words the Earth tree governs all
the choice is thine
become one with the order
or divest thyself of it
to wallow at the fringes
a powerless upstart but the greater will
needed more than a big tree it needed
loyal agents in the lands between to
this end it has the two fingers who are
its envoys the two fingers heirloom has
a weird picture of them but it reads of
course fingers cannot speak yet these
are eloquent persistently they wriggle
spelling out mysteries in the air thus
did we gain the words the words of our
faith these words are interpreted by the
finger readers these are the undying old
Crohn's that you would have found
throughout the lands between they passed
down the wisdom of the two fingers or at
least they used to your fingers please
your fingers
I can read them most of them appear to
have lost their purpose and they're
desperate to read your fingers and tell
you annoying riddles since their two
fingers are likely dead and yes of
course there are multiple sets of two
fingers you would have found their
corpses on the tops of the Divine Towers
atop these towers you loot the fingers
in order to activate the true power of a
great Rune specifically though you are
giving benediction back to your great
Rune you're taking a blessing back from
the two dead fingers essentially this is
just one of many blessings that the two
fingers can bestow and my point is kind
of that the two fingers clearly have
more than just influence they have real
power on some level the greater will
needs these powerful envoys and agents
because while it's obviously incredibly
powerful it does seem limited by a few
things first is space the greater will
didn't come to the lands between itself
it sent an Elden Beast to do its bidding
instead second is time there is a moment
later in the game where your pair of two
fingers goes still because they're
forced to commune with the greater will
for guidance when they are finished
the fingers will again offer their
guidance about thousands if not tens of
thousands of moons must first pass no
matter for me
but you
how will you ever manage to wait so the
greater will needs a physical
manifestation of order it needs envoys
to convey its will but what it also
needs is a god introducing America the
Eternal I have this utterly enormous
mind map of Elden Ring's law and there's
a reason she's at the center she's
essentially the equivalent of Gwyn from
Dark Souls except unlike Gwyn America
didn't just crawl out of the dark and
find power to an extent it seems like
she earned it we don't know much about
her Origins except that she is of the
Newman Race which is actually An Origin
that you can choose in the character
selection screen Newman come from
outside the lands between and our
supposed descendants of denizens of
another world long-lived but seldom born
at some point Marika was chosen as an
empyrean what is an Imperium well an
imperian is a being chosen by the
fingers as a candidate for godhood as an
emperion America received received the
aid of a shadow to do her bidding so
what is a shadow well it's a wolf Shadow
bound to its Imperium by the two fingers
Luna princess Rani is another example of
an imperian with a shadow-bound beast
you would have met live these creatures
are the imperian's very own shadow they
are completely loyal to their needs and
by definition incapable of treachery
America's Shadow was a beast called
malacath every Imperium uses their
shadow in different ways but America's
sole need of her Shadow was as a vessel
to lock away destined death so what is
destined death well according to Enya it
the Rune of death the rule of death goes
by two names
the other is destined death we mentioned
earlier that the Elden ring is made up
of runes and at some point maybe when
she was chosen as a god America plucked
the Rune of death from the Eldon ring
she gave the Rune of death to malikath
her totally loyal Shadow Who Bore a
Black Blade imbued with this Rune it's
kind of Genius really in a single act
she removed the concept of death from
the lands between while also commanding
total control of death through her
Shadow who could deliver it at her win
now some of you might be asking if death
is removed from the lands between how
come I can kill this dog first off shame
on you second from a law point of view
that dog isn't really dead it's simply
in the process of its Spirit or its Soul
returning to the urge tree catacomb
dungeons for example are specifically
constructed near the roots of the great
tree for this reason so that the Earth
tree can reabsorb their ashes back into
it this process replaced the concept of
a death that you were destined to have
but this random Spirit outside of a
catacomb dungeon says it best
[Applause]
as another example of this Theory when
you kill a major boss you receive a
remembrance of them these are spirits
and they are hewn into the old tree in
this way thanks to the Earth trees Grace
their Spirits are immortalized in a
sense this new form of death also
explains what's happening when you
summon Spirits from Ash and return to
the Earth tree
however some Spirits never return to the
Earth tree and they rise within death as
corpses or skeletons instead
all right
[Applause]
so this was the New Order and it's
important to stress that it was in this
moment when the Rune of death was
removed when destined death was taken
this is when order became the golden
order the Forbidden Shadow plucked from
the golden order upon its creation
specifically this was America's golden
order so not only did she become a God
and a vessel for the Elden ring she
became renowned as Marika the Eternal
for her removal of destined death it was
a huge part of her character and her
reign as well
however America had more than just death
to conquer she had Wars to fight as the
world was occupied by many forces that
could threaten her golden order there
was war with the stormlord who likely
ruled over stormvale there was a war
with the Giants who were masters of a
flame that could burn the urge tree
there was war with the ancient Dragons
Who incidentally had stones that could
twist time and thus slay a God and
finally there was war brewing with the
carrion royalty who had previously
obeyed laws which contravened the golden
order
thus sort of similar to how the greater
will needed an imperian to enforce its
will Marika herself needed someone to
wage war so there was to be a husband a
consort an Elden Lord
the man chosen was Hora Lou a ferocious
Warrior who became known as the lord of
the battlefield his crown was warranted
with strength and while it was for this
strength that America married him he was
also required to take a vow to conduct
himself as a lord to suppress the
ceaseless lust for battle that raged
within horalu took the Beast Regent
sarosh upon his back you'll notice this
is another example of a beast being
given for the purpose of serving order
thus In This Moment he went from being
horalu Warrior to Godfrey the first
Elden Lord consort to Queen America and
a certified demigod
Godfrey and America had three demigod
children together there was Godwin the
golden who you saw being killed in the
opening trailer and they were also the
reviled Omen twins morgot who guards the
Earth tree and Moog who became Lord of
blood you might think that godric was
another demigod child but he actually
wasn't instead he was probably descended
from Godwin anyway we'll talk about the
demigods more in detail in another video
so subscribe for that but for now just
know that Godfrey and his offspring were
the first demigods henceforth known as
the golden lineage
in his Wars Godfrey LED his 16 Crucible
Knights into battle who were named so
for they fought with the primordial
powers of the earth tree their
incantations were aspects of The
Crucible itself and they likely fought
Giants dragons the stormlord and more to
usher in their age the age of the herd
Tree in America's own words
hark brave warriors
Park my Lord Godfrey we commend your
Deeds guidance hath delivered ye through
each ordeal to the place ye stand put
the Giants to the sword and confine the
flame Atop The mount let a new Epoch
begin
an Epoch glistening with life brandish
the Eldon ring for the age of the Earth
tree
the old tree would go on to be largely
seen as a blessing for all of those in
the lands between especially those close
to it in Langdale the capital city of
the oak tree the tree bestowed blessings
for example the Dew that dropped from
its branches were like Jewels it loomed
overhead as a constant reminder of order
and its roots reached far and wide
relieving many of the burden of death in
fact ERD tree burial was one of the
highest honors a hero could receive
one by one the previous factions of the
world fell the Giants were put to the
sword and their fell God was killed by
America herself the ancient dragons
Broke Down the Walls of Langdale but met
Fierce retaliation however I think the
house of the earth tree encountered the
most trouble against the land to their
Southwest Leonia here the house of the
Moon repelled their offensives time and
time again and I mean that literally
because there was not just one but two
wars fought here and in both of these
there was no victory for the golden nor
for the moon and I suspect it was
probably because of these lobsters these
damn things can snipe you from like a
mile away and it's bullsh actually it
was probably because of the carrion
Knights who according to their weapons
were able to wield sorceress battle
skills and despite numbering fewer than
20 this power made them a match for even
the champions of gold in battle these
Enchanted Knights were anointed by the
lunar Queen a young astrologer who went
on to establish the house of caria as
royalty in this land with her bewitching
lunar magic she won over the Academy of
Raya lucaria where glenstone's sorcery
was studied and United the carrion royal
family and the Learned Scholars of Raya
lucaria defended their home from the
golden aggressors at the head of this
great Golden Army was radagon Lord
Radigan was a great Champion possessed
of flowing red locks he came to these
lands at the head of a great golden host
when he met lady ranala in battle these
two Champions clashed fell in love and
joined their houses Radigan once
cleansed himself with Celestial Dew
repented his Territorial aggressions and
swore his love to ronalda the order of
the earth tree and the fate of the moon
were conjoined and all the wounds of War
forgiven you might think it's strange
that the greater will would permit this
Union but it's not too odd all things
considered as with most from software
games sorcery and Faith are just two
sides of the same coin and both of these
Powers stem from the cosmos
radagon and ranala were known to have
three children together
Luna princess Rani who inherited her
mother's propensity for lunar magic
radon who took after his father radagon
and would go on to master gravitational
magic and Reichard who pioneered new hex
sorceries and would go on to feed
himself to a Great Serpent
it follows that at some point after this
America began to Harbor doubts doubts
about the golden order that she had had
a hand in creating in America's own
words I declare my intent
to search the depths of the golden order
through understanding of the proper way
our faith
our Grace is increased those Blissful
early days of blind belief are long past
my comrades
why must you falter
and it's at this point that we should
talk about America's motivations her
character this is surely going to be one
of those huge points of debate in the
coming years but for now my working
theory is that she wanted to discover
the truth behind order and the truth
behind the greater will and she believed
that bonds had to be broken so that they
could be better understood she believed
that there was great meaning to be found
in hardship Queen Marica has high hopes
for us that we continue to struggle onto
Eternity for Lord Godfrey his struggle
ended at the end of his campaigns
according to his armor he led the war
against the Giants faced the storm Lord
alone and then there came a moment when
his last worthy enemy fell and it was
then as the story is told that the Hue
of Lord Godfrey's eyes faded in truth he
was robbed of his grace then Maraca sent
him away my Lord
and thy Warriors
I divest each of thee of thy Grace
With Thine Eyes dimmed ye will be driven
from the lands between
ye will wage war in a land afar
[Music]
where you will live
and die
this became known as the Long March of
the tarnished as Godfrey and his
tarnished descendants walked away from
the lands between but Queen America
absolutely had a plan here that Lord
Godfrey and his descendants would one
day return stronger having struggled
outside of Grace then
after thy death
I will give back what I once claimed
return to the lands between
wage war
and brandished the Eldon ring grow
strong in the face of death
Warriors of my Lord
Godfrey
soon after she found a new husband
either that or a new husband was found
for her when Godfrey first Elden Lord
was hounded from the lands between
Radigan left renala to return to the
Earth tree capital
becoming Queen marika's second husband
and King consort taking the title of
second Elden Lord
the mystery endures to this day as to
why Lord Radigan would cast lady Ronaldo
aside and moreover why a mere Champion
would be chosen for the seat of golden
Lord
whatever the case as a part of this
Union radagon's prior three children
with rinala became demigod stepchildren
granted Grace thanks to their new family
tree
Ronaldo was broken by this and so was
her country Leonia the queen set reads
when ronalda head of both the Academy of
Raya lucaria and the carrion royal
family lost her husband radagon her
heart went along with him and then those
at the Academy realized that ranala was
no champion after all in the wake of
radagon's betrayal and ranala's poor
judgment Leonia struggled with civil war
with the Academy of Raya lucaria on one
side and the carrion Royals on the other
and it's here during the age of the
Earth tree that Luna princess Rani
daughter of Ronaldo and radagon stole a
fragment of the Rune of death it
happened during the golden age of the
Earth tree long before the shattering of
the Elden ring
someone stole a fragment of the Rune of
Death From malacath the Black Blade as
mentioned previously malikath was
America's Shadow and he had sealed
destined death in a Black Blade then a
fragment only a fragment of this Rune of
death was stolen and once this happened
malikath went a step further in
protecting destined death he bound the
blade within his own flesh such that
none might rob death ever again it was
too late however this fragment of the
Rune of death was used immediately that
night to kill a demigod America's own
son Godwin the golden that was the first
recorded death of a demigod in all
history and it became the Catalyst soon
the Elden ring was smashed and thus
sprang forth the war known as the
shattering now there is a lot of really
credible evidence that America was
behind this plot to have a fragment of
the Rune of death stole
there's also a ton of evidence that
America is behind the entirety of your
tarnished Quest but we'll talk about
that in another video for now all you
really need to know in terms of the
timeline at least is this after the
marriage of America and radagon and
after a fragment of the Rune of death
was stolen America went on to shatter
the Elden ring and radagon attempted to
repair it to no avail the olden ring had
been broken into runes some great and
some small you know it's said that Lord
Radigan harbored a secret a famed
sculptor of the earth tree Capital was
once summoned to render Lord radican's
likeness in Giant stature when he
glimpsed the skeleton in radican's
closet and as such it said the great
statue Harbors his secret too of course
the huge twist in Elden ring is that
radagon is America or depending on what
you believe he became her for she knew
it was going to happen in America's own
words oh radican
Leo Hound of the golden order that yet
to become me
the art yet to become a God let us be
shattered
both
mine other self
you can tell when a from software is
keeping something a little bit
open-ended and of everything in Eldon
Ring's law this will also go on to be
one of the biggest unknowns as we move
forward for example the wording Thou Art
yet to become me reinforces that America
and radagon were two separate entities
before the shattering however in
contrast there is also evidence that
radagon was always part of America for
example Enya says that the Demi chords
are each and all the direct offspring of
Queen America
but how can this be if radagon married
Ronaldo and had those demigod children
the only way that makes sense is if
radagon was always America and he just
went over there to seduce ranala long
ago I'll present more concrete theories
in the future but on this matter the
most important thing is what do you
think while you can figure out a ton of
Elden Ring's story not all of it is open
to interpretation certain things are and
this is one of them and your
interpretation is a big part of what
makes this story special
at any rate the union of radagon and
America seems to be a union of two
fundamental opposing laws of the golden
order we mentioned these laws earlier
actually there's the law of causality
and America is an agent of cause and
effect and there's the law of regression
as radagon is a character who aspires to
be complete and regress together so I
have a theory that forcing these two
beings that represent these Concepts
together would have corrected America's
deviance but even so she was imprisoned
in the urge tree for the crime of the
shattering Malika's trespass demanded a
heavy sentence but even in shackles she
remains a God and a Visions vessel the
conjoined radagon and Marika even had
two demigod children of their own mikola
and Millennia these two children were
born Afflicted mikola was cursed with
eternal childhood and Millennia harbored
a horrific rot Within
even so these two children were both
chosen as imperians they were immensely
sacred beings and eligible to inherit
godhood from the greater will
perhaps the greater will was just
desperate to find a worthy successor and
indeed in the shattering War to come
many would try to claim the shards of
the Eldon ring and they would try to
take the throne including of course the
tarnished who returned from their long
march at long last
which we'll talk about in the next main
lore video I should probably also
mention here that if you become a patron
you'll see upcoming lore videos early as
that's one of the rewards you get if you
pledge to the three dollar tier and if
you think my channel really adds a lot
of value to the souls games for you to
the point where you pledge 20 then in
this new tier you'll receive a new mug
every three months that has a unique
design on it to do with the games by
from software there are four to collect
the first one you'll get is inspired by
Dark Souls then Elden ring then sakuro
and finally bloodborne and they all have
fantastic art that I worked on with an
amazing artist named chu but anyway I
figured this is the right place to end
this video because the information here
is going to be overwhelming I bet it
probably was too overwhelming you know
it took me ages to commit these names
and the relationships they had with
other characters to memory so I hope you
guys are doing all right one thing that
helped me a lot was that we designed an
enormous mind map with pretty much all
of Elden rings all of its item
descriptions all of its dialogues all of
the relationships between characters
that we can think of we added all of
this together and it helped a ton in
learning about the story and visualizing
it all and one day I will make this
asset available to you all because I
think after doing it I think this is the
quintessential way to piece together the
story and I think giving you guys this
asset eventually will make that
accessible for people so I'm really
excited about that I want to thank Absa
and zard for accepting the paid task of
helping me put all the raw data into
this mind map so that I could better
understand everything I want to thank
paragod for fulfilling all of my footage
requests and creating so many cinematic
scenes for this video and for you all to
enjoy and I last of all want to thank
John Devlin for the incredible thumbnail
and of course thank you for watching
there are some really exciting things
ahead and I actually believe this might
be the best story that from software
I've ever put together other I just
think not only are there so many amazing
item descriptions but so many of them
are impactful there are so many moments
where you piece together the story and
have like a Eureka moment and I'm
enjoying it so much but now I'm gonna go
and play the game a little bit because
I've been editing this video for too
long so see you next time
[Music]